We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21centri.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This is the first joke I ever really noticed as a design joke. I like an escalator, Matt, because an escalator
我们得到了全球知名大学加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，该校致力于解决当今世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加利福尼亚州以及全球各地合作创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命。请访问 21centri.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是“99%无形”。我是罗曼·马斯。这是我真正注意到作为设计笑话的第一个笑话。我喜欢自动扶梯，马特，因为自动扶梯
can never break. It can only become stairs. That's Mitch Hedberg. All right. There would never be an escalator temporarily out of order sign. Only an escalator temporarily stairs. Sorry for the convenience. Being designed to elegantly deal with the extreme failure
永远不会坏。它只会变成楼梯。这是米奇·赫德berg说的。好吧。永远不会有一个“自动扶梯暂停使用”的标牌。只有“自动扶梯临时变为楼梯”。为您的便利感到抱歉。被设计为优雅地处理极端故障
case is probably an under-appreciated design element, but it really is one of the things that makes an escalator great. Worst case, they're stairs. See how far you get in a broken elevator. I bet everyone wants escalators. I'm enjoying that design aspect too. And we're getting our cardio. That's 99% in visible zone, Sam Greenspan walking up
情况可能是被低估的设计元素，但它确实是让自动扶梯变得伟大的元素之一。最坏的情况下，它们是楼梯。看看你在坏掉的电梯里能走多远。我敢打赌每个人都想要自动扶梯。我也很喜欢那个设计方面。我们在做有氧运动。这是“99%隐形”特派员山姆·格林斯潘在走上
an escalator in a metro station in DC. Ever since the industrial revolution when it became possible for products to be designed just once and then mass produced, it has been the slight failures and imperfections and the individual wear and tear introduced by human use that transforms a quality, mass produced product into a thing we actually love. Your worn-in blue jeans, your grandmother's iron skillet, the initial design determined
华盛顿特区地铁站的自动扶梯。自从工业革命以来，产品有可能只设计一次然后大规模生产，正是人类使用带来的微小故障、缺陷以及个人的磨损，将一个优质的量产产品变成了我们真正热爱的事物。你穿旧的牛仔裤，你祖母的铁锅，最初的设计决定了
its quality, but it's there post-manufacturing imperfections that make them comfortable, that make them lovable, that make them yours. If you think a slightly broken escalator can't be lovable, well maybe you haven't been paying attention. An escalator on a DC Metro platform is like a fine wine. It's better with age and without any industrial lubricant. Sam lives in Baltimore now, but he lived in DC for a few years. He said that this sound came to embody the excitement he felt from living in a city. Yeah, I mean, I grew up in one of Florida's most depressing suburbs. I mean, it's just miles and miles of highways and coals to sack.
它的质量，但正是制造后的缺陷让它们感到舒适，让它们讨人喜欢，让它们成为你的专属。如果你认为一个稍微坏掉的自动扶梯不能讨人喜欢，那也许你没有注意到。华盛顿特区地铁站台上的自动扶梯就像一瓶好酒。它随着时间推移而变得更好，而且没有任何工业润滑剂。山姆现在住在巴尔的摩，但他在华盛顿特区住了几年。他说，这种声音开始具体化他对生活在一座城市所感受到的兴奋。是的，我的意思是，我在佛罗里达州最令人沮丧的郊区之一长大。我的意思是，那只有一英里又一英里的高速公路和死胡同。
Very nice. Thank you. So when I moved to DC, I took public transit everywhere just because I could. The DC Metro system, it's not the best in the world, but it's pretty good. Although a lot of people do lament the poor condition of the Metro's escalators. Some are just flat out broken, and then there are some that work but make these crazy noises. Which, you know, annoy a lot of people, but for me, I found that a skrunking escalator was like this little trumpeter announcing how awesome it was to live in the city
非常好。谢谢。所以当我搬到华盛顿特区时，我到处乘坐公共交通，只是因为我可以。华盛顿特区的地铁系统虽然不是世界上最好的，但它相当不错。尽管许多人确实哀叹地铁自动扶梯状况不佳。有些直接坏了，还有一些能运行但发出奇怪的噪音。你知道，这惹恼了很多人，但对我和来说，我发现吱吱作响的自动扶梯就像一个微型小号手，宣告着住在城市里是多么棒
It turns out that someone else loves this sound too. So this is Chris Richards I'm the pop music critic at the Washington Post Chris was also in a band called Q and not U He wrote a kind of appreciation of the Metro escalators for the post We're at the Farragut North Metro station in Washington, D.C. on the north side of El Street in Connecticut Avenue. Chris told me that he had never really noticed the sound that the escalators made until one day when he was on a bit of a free jazz kick. Having my ear train for those sort of breath on brass kind of sounds, I think maybe turning
事实证明，其他人也很喜欢这个声音。所以这是克里斯·理查兹，我是《华盛顿邮报》的流行音乐评论员。克里斯还曾在一个名为 Q and not U 的乐队里。他为《邮报》写了一篇关于地铁自动扶梯的赞赏文章。我们在华盛顿特区位于康涅狄格大道埃尔街北侧的法拉格特北地铁站。克里斯告诉我，他以前从未真正注意到自动扶梯发出的声音，直到有一天他在听一点自由爵士乐。我的耳朵训练了那种对黄铜呼吸的声音，我想也许有一天转
the corner to come down the escalators one day. I thought, oh, there's a saxophone player playing at the bottom of the metro, but it wasn't that at all. This is the escalator is kind of like walking and screeching away. Maybe they were, I don't know if they were always this loud. On the escalator, there's a plastic element on the side of each step that keeps it from rubbing against the metal siding. A lubricant keeps it all running smoothly, but when a ranger snows, the lubrication wears off. So what you're hearing when you hear these kind of like moaning squawks is the steel stairs sort of rubbing up and chafing against that plastic element when it's gotten a little too dry.
过拐角走下自动扶梯时。我想，哦，地铁底部有一个萨克斯风手在演奏，但根本不是那样。这是自动扶梯有点像在走路和尖叫。也许它们是，我不知道它们是否总是这么吵。在自动扶梯上，每个台阶的侧面都有一个塑料元件，可以防止它与金属侧板摩擦。润滑剂使一切顺畅运行，但当下雪时，润滑油会磨损。所以当你听到这种像呻吟般的尖叫声时，你听到的是钢质楼梯在变得有点太干时与那个塑料元件摩擦和擦伤的声音。
Kind of like a beautiful serendipitous aftershock of the wear and tear that these escalators are facing. It sounds like music. And like any good music critic, Chris started classifying the different styles of metro escalator. So here at Fair music critic, Chris started classifying the different styles of Metro escalator. So here at Fair Good North, the escalators might sound like... Whales mating. Or something like that. Whereas the escalator at Eustreet kind of sounded like Indian drone music.
有点像这些自动扶梯面临的磨损带来的美丽、偶然的余震。听起来像音乐。像任何优秀的音乐评论员一样，克里斯开始对不同风格的地铁自动扶梯进行分类。所以在这里，公平的音乐评论员克里斯开始对不同风格的地铁自动扶梯进行分类。所以在这里，法拉格特北站，自动扶梯的声音可能听起来像……鲸鱼交配。或者类似的东西。而埃尔街的自动扶梯听起来有点像印度无伴奏合唱音乐。
And Columbia Heights. An aviary of chrome-throated ravens taunting you as you descend into your workday. We understand that we could be over romanticizing escrowing and squeaking escalator. You can talk all day about appreciating the ambiance soundscape around you and get really into a stethisized ways of listening Chris Richards was big on this by the way, but you could also just as easily say, you know, hey, this is all noise.
还有哥伦比亚高地。当你走入工作日时，一群镀铬喉咙的乌鸦在嘲讽你。我们明白，我们可能把转义和吱吱作响的自动扶梯过度浪漫化了。你可以整天谈论欣赏周围的环境音景，并真正沉浸在氛围化的聆听方式中。顺便说一句，克里斯·理查兹在这方面很有一套，但你同样可以轻而易举地说，你知道，嘿，这都是噪音。
I think it's all really an air of the beholder. Yeah, it is totally understandable that people wouldn't appreciate a screeching escalator. Chris actually told me that when he called up Metro for his story, their PR people didn't believe him. They thought he was writing some big expose about escalator failure. Quite the opposite really. I was trying to say, you know, even though these things are a little bit beat down, this is a wonderful little residual bonus. I guess. My point of view is if you're going to be subjected to some kind of sensory experience of which you have no control every single day, then it's to your benefit. It's, you know, why not try to enjoy something because there's enough things in life to be
我认为这一切真的取决于听众。是的，人们不欣赏刺耳的自动扶梯是完全可以理解的。克里斯实际上告诉我，当他为他的故事打电话给地铁时，他们的公关人员不相信他。他们以为他在写一些关于自动扶梯故障的重大曝光文章。恰恰相反。我想说的是，你知道，尽管这些东西有点破旧，但这是一个极好的微小残留红利。我想。我的观点是，如果你每天都要经历某种你无法控制的感觉体验，那么这对你是有利的。你知道，为什么不试着享受一些东西，因为生活中有很多事情要
stressed out about. As much as people complain about what all the sounds that cities make and all the noises that cities make, I think those noises define it and really become our environment. The sound can be an irritation or it can be information. Chris got me hoping the escalators never get fixed, except the ones that just straight up don't work. The escalator at the Wheaton stop, it is the longest escalator in the western hemisphere. It takes 3 minutes to ride to the top when it's working.
感到压力。正如人们抱怨城市发出的所有声音和城市发出的所有噪音一样，我认为这些声音定义了它，并真正成为了我们的环境。声音可以是一种刺激，也可以是信息。克里斯让我希望自动扶梯永远不会修好，除了那些直接坏掉的。惠顿站的自动扶梯是西半球最长的自动扶梯。正常运行需要3分钟才能骑到顶部。
Let's hope that the Wheaton escalator doesn't conveniently become stairs anytime soon. 99% Invisible was produced this week by our intern Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars. It was adapted from an episode of Sam's podcast Whisper Cities, a show about overlooked places and the people who find them. Find out more at WhisperCities.org. This program is made possible with support from the lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW-91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design.
让我们希望惠顿自动扶梯不会在不久的将来方便地变成楼梯。“99%隐形”本周由我们的实习生山姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马斯制作。它改编自山姆的播客“低语城市”的一集，这是一个关于被忽视的地方以及发现它们的人的节目。在 WhisperCities.org 了解更多信息。这个节目是在月球的支持下得以实现的，用创造力创造不同。它是旧金山本地公共广播 KALW-91.7、旧金山美国建筑师学会以及建筑与设计中心的合作项目。
99% Invisible is distributed by PRX, the public radio exchange, making public radio more public. Find out more at prx.org. To find out more or keep in touch with us especially if you want to tell us about your favorite sound which you know, which you know for a fact is somebody else's noise, go to our website you you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“99%隐形”由 PRX（公共广播交流中心）分发，使公共广播更加公共。在 prx.org 了解更多信息。要了解更多信息或与我们保持联系，特别是如果您想告诉我们您最喜欢的声音（你知道，这实际上是别人的噪音），请访问我们的网站。这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子发表评论。